now the so-called jungle camp in Calais
is to close this week and the UK
government is hurrying to fulfill its
promise to bring unaccompanied minors to
Britain one of those Sue's led to fight
of course to bring the children of Carly
to brittany's the Labour MP stella
creasy who joins me now very good to see
if I mean your your overall feel on the
closure of this campus art you know it's
not a good thing or a bad thing it seems
that you've been there on awful place
look what's a bad thing is that there
are 10,000 people who are asking for
help and they haven't had an answer of
whom a thousand of them are children now
tomorrow the bulldozers and the French
police are going to start to move in and
that question still remains what happens
to those people how do we treat them
fairly and with dignity and the problem
has been that for so long people have
wanted to avoid the question answering
it and doing it in a way that is fair
and people can have confidence in its
happening at very short notice and so we
get this promise that the UK government
is made about unaccompanied down to deed
miners who have a right to be here
because of family links it's all seems
very last minute well that we passed the
Dubs amendment in name of the amazing
elf dubs back in May this year I went
out to cali over the summer and one of
the things that struck me very simply
there was just nobody there to make that
then happen now I think the government
should get plaudits for the fact that
actually things have started to move but
it's all see happening at very short
notice and that's the real concern for
many of us still a lot to do there was
an EU referendum around do you think we
think it was that I think for too long
the government has felt this has been
somebody else's problem and actually as
you say many of those children and the
children you seen come here this week
have family here so under international
law they've had the right to be here in
fact citizens UK informed our government
back in July of a hundred children who
had the right to be in the UK then in
August they gave them another list of
children and then in September they gave
them a list of children who under the
Dubs amendment we felt it was in their
best interest to be here in the UK that
it has taken until October to act is a
problem but they are acting and I think
they should get recognition for that why
do you think that problem developed well
that would be a question you need to ask
perhaps to resume who was of course
responsible for this and indeed a mirage
what we're focused on right now is look
100 children also have come here and
yesterday we saw the first
girls coming here we saw the first
children coming under the Dubs amendment
that's just one percent of that total
population in Calais and there are still
a lot of children who need an answer who
do need processing and I I cannot stress
enough and one of the things that has
been so depressing this week as people
querying this safe and legal route which
has involved a lot of verification a lot
of checks it's taken a lot of work by
the voluntary organizations to get it
right those children are starting to
come here but there are still many more
that when those bulldozers move in will
be in Calais and meet on to say the
questioning you mean those that might
not be 18 might not be under 18 I mean
those people who have downloaded a
twitter app which is a great fun app to
check people's age and somehow decided
that they are experts in our immigration
and asylum system and one of the things
I say to people about all of this is
look it's absolutely right to ask
questions but it's done wrong not to do
your homework the tests that are being
done in Calais this is a legal and safe
route for these children to come here
that is why they are coming here that's
why y'all cheering me that is
significant if some of them are children
well I mean there's that statistic
wasn't there they up to September 2015
two-thirds of so-called children a
variety or actually turned out not I'm
really glad you're asking about a
statistic to it let's debunk it goes
actually what that statistic was about
was the total number of children who
have been here illegally you arrived
illegally so for example they turn up at
Heathrow of then a proportion of whom
there were queries about their age then
the proportion of those that actually it
was found they were not young so
actually eighty percent of the children
in total were children not sixty percent
weren't children there's some very very
shady work being done about the numbers
and it speaks to a broader problem that
we have here which is actually if we
want to do the right thing which is say
actually a young child who has nobody
else in the world we will do our fair
share of helping them because they're
fleeing from a war zone they're fleeing
from conflict actually we've got to have
confidence and trust in our system so
ask the questions but then do your own
work but what about dental checks I mean
apparently 17 other European countries
carry that carry those are we against
that again and I know people find
experts perhaps a bit old-hat but I'm
going to listen to dentists on this and
dentists will tell you it's not an
accurate test so first and foremost it
would be a waste of money and also it's
actually quite bad for your health
because it does involve radiation so
really are we going to say that it's in
Britain's interest
best of Britain to apply a test to a
child that is bad for their health
because we don't think the other
extensive tests which involve their
paperwork interviews talking to their
family members are here in the UK to
verify their stories are better I think
people need to be proud of the fact that
actually albeit far too late the
government has started to get a process
in place they should be worried about
the children who are still there and
getting it right for them and we need to
make sure we have a better system in
place so this doesn't happen again what
about the children then that do get here
hmm I mean someone spoke Asians in some
of their cases of out of the frying pan
into the fire because they're not being
adequately looked after they've been
stuck we're hearing today in one of
these detention centres which isn't
adequate is it no I'm one of the things
about this is that just getting these
children here is the start of helping
them get their lives back on track you
know many of these children could go on
to do amazing things in our communities
if we can help them get back on my feet
they've seen some horrific things
they're incredibly vulnerable they've
got a lot of psychological problems
they're coming from war zones conflicts
they've seen their parents be killed
it's a horrific place so actually when
they get here they need either to be
reunited with their family so they have
some stability or they need decent
fostering places and a new star but I
think it's a really powerful testament
to the goodwill of the British people
that we're prepared to do that how many
would you take I mean would you take as
many as are there when you take every
child who has a legal right to be here
in the UK so when I met children Calais
who had family here in the UK who'd been
there for months there were children who
gave up hope and they tried to get here
illegally and a couple of them actually
ended up dying some of them have gone
missing in that time period those
children had a legal rights to be here I
think we still have responsibility for
them I've been asking the government you
might have seen me get up and ask
Theresa May directly what's happened to
those children there were 18 of them
that we knew had gone missing have we
found them yet so I think those we have
a legal right to for the children who
have nobody else in the world so the
Dubs children maybe their parents have
been killed they've been completely lost
then actually I think we should take our
fair share now I think that's about
looking at what we can do with the
French but we're talking about a
thousand children so in total 500 seems
to me a pretty good number